thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
how are you guys doing today is going to
be a different kind of flavor a
different kind of thing that we're going
to be doing together because we usually
do reaction videos we should talk about
current affairs or current things that
are happening today we're going to talk
about something completely different
which is
probably more important than all that in
fact definitely one problem with all
that which is
the prayer
the most important thing for a Muslim to
do the action that if a Muslim does five
times a day will differentiate them and
distinguish them from the disbelievers
as the Hadith States
and we're going to kind of think about
the spiritual implications the inner
dimensions of the prayer in fact there's
a nice book
translated into English called the inner
dimensions of prayer so let's go through
the Islamic prayer bit by bit
when you start the prayer you say Allahu
Akbar and you put your hands up okay
we're not going to do the figure of this
more the spiritual aspect means
Allah is the greatest
that's what that means so as you're
doing that you imagine that Allah
is watching you you imagine that Allah
is with you of course you don't imagine
he's with you in essence but you imagine
that he's with you
and that he can hear what you're saying
and then you start the praying you say
alhamdulillah
and you mentioned
saying that all praise and thanks be
Allah be to Allah lord of the worlds the
most gracious the most merciful
Master of the day of judgment
you alone we worship and you alone will
ask for help guide us to the straight
path the path of those who you have
favored not the path of those who have
earned your anger
none of those who've gone astray now
you're thinking about this and you're in
the present moment
you're not thinking about what's going
to happen later on
about the bills about this about that
about these anxieties that you have
about your relationships
about business you're not thinking about
all these things
you're literally praying and thinking
that this is all that there is
this is all that there is
there's nothing else going on at the
moment
in fact the future doesn't exist
there's no such thing as Refugee that's
what you're thinking that's this is how
to get sure in the prayer you see
there's no future
only this conversation that you're
having with Allah the Creator the lord
of the heavens and the Earth at this
point in time the future doesn't exist
you're in a state of
your present with Allah and that means
that there is no future everything is
just about that moment
you're clear in your mind and then
you're doing your other Surah
maybe whatever
again you're going down to the back
position
and you're humbling yourself
you're calm
and you say subhanallah
and that means glory be to the one who
is
Ali means mighty
and you're not humble bowing
positioning
and then you come back up
that Allah has heard the one who has
praised him that's what that means
because some people say this phrase and
they don't know what it means and then
you say hunt
oh and our Lord to you belongs praise
that's what
mean means
and then now you go down
and you say subhanallah
and you are prostrating
and you're the highest part of your head
is in the most low part of the ground
and you're saying glory be to the one
who is most high
you're saying that three times
foreign
this is a very deep situation right now
and you're thinking about that and
you're humble this is a very relaxing
position this is a very peaceful
position this is the most peaceful
position you can imagine this is the
best situation
there's nothing more important than that
position in the entire day there's
nothing more important than that
position in your entire life in fact
so you're in that position
this is why you are created
this is the purpose of life
this is everything you need to know
this is everything you need to do
there's nothing more to life than this
then you come back up
you say
you know
Allah forgive me Allah forgive because
we've done lots of sins
so we're being a bit accountable here
and you go back down
after you've asked Allah the king
to forgive you you go back down
subhanallah again
and that's one unit of prayer and you
repeat that and and so on
if you get this right
you get hello man you get the sweetness
of faith
because we have five prayers a day this
is a really beautiful Yani meditation
um kind of exercise not the kind of
meditation that these mushriks do
and the ones who worship other than God
no you're worshiping Allah
there's nothing greater that you can do
as a human being you know that there's
nothing but there's nothing better you
can do with your time
there's no money that you can amass
there is no Fame that you can get
there's no you know adornments that you
can put on there's nothing
this is peace
this is
this is surely with the remembrance of
Allah find rest
make sure that when you're praying next
time you think about those things
the Prophet Muhammad
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a Sim at the house in
Jannah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays that whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale